spider-man vs. venom something that we
have all just been waiting for for an
extremely long time now and have been
dying to see what's up everyone its
Warren and there's been a lot of talk
about this recently especially with the
Sony Marvel deal that just happened
there's been a lot of speculation in
regards to spider-man finally facing off
against venom and either one of the
universes but now we can officially say
with a confirmation that spider-man and
venom are going to be facing off against
one another and this was actually
revealed to us by a director at Sony so
it's the real thing this is happening so
let's talk about what was said but a
quick reminder about my giveaway if
you'd like a chance to win an Xbox one
or a ps4 be sure to subscribe to my
channel like this video and leave a
comment down below so fandom recently
had an interview with ruben fleischer
along with the rest of the cast of
Zombieland
now Ruben directed Zombieland but he
also directed the first venom movie now
Ruben is not directing venom to Andy
Serkis is going to be directing venom
two but Ruben says he was happy to hand
the franchise over in the interview it
is stated that Andy Serkis has said he
has very clear ideas for the film and
who could well ultimately orchestrate an
introduction for spider-man in the
interview ruben fleischer says that he's
excited to see how Tom Hardy's venom and
Tom Hollands webslinger would come
together he revealed that's where it's
all going to lead and that's the
exciting thing because we changed the
origin of venom and the comics he
evolved from spider-man but because of
the Marvel Sony thing we weren't able to
do that and so the thing I think it's
building towards and we'll be excited to
see is when they actually do confront
each other so two major confirmations
here in the interview it is stated that
Andy Serkis who is going to direct venom
2 has good ideas on how to orchestrate
spider-man into venom and then you have
ruben fleischer who was the director of
the first venom movie say that sony's
plans all along was to ultimately lead
up to a spider-man venom movie now of
course he had to mention the Marvel deal
now because of the contract that Sony
had with Marvel for spider-man to be in
the MCU they couldn't exactly do what
they wanted to with spider-man we
actually know that Sony wanted Tom
Holland to appear in the first venom
film but ultimately Marvel said no
however recently as we know
Marvel and Sony have worked out a new
deal for spider-man to remain in the MCU
and it is very possible that that deal
could have included a Tom Hollands
spider-man appearance in venom which
would make a lot of sense because as we
just heard it seems like Sony's plan the
entire time was to build a venom up to
eventually have a spider-man crossover
the sad thing is is after hearing this
confirmation it does not seem like we're
going to be getting spider-man in venom
to most likely going to be venom 3 and
since it's ruben fleischer and andy
serkis who are confirming the fact that
spider-man and venom will eventually
meet this will most likely take place in
the venom verse and not the MCU so sadly
but also not so sadly the next
spider-man film and the emcee will most
likely focus on the sinister six so
unfortunately it's not looking like
we're going to see venom in the MCU but
it does look like we're going to see Tom
Hollands spider-man enter the
spider-verse
in venom 3 insane news absolutely
incredible to finally get a venom
spider-man crossover since the original
spider-man 3 Tom Hardy's venom is
awesome and Tom Hollands spider-man is
awesome it's going to be a great movie
when it finally comes out so let me know
what everybody thinks about this how do
you think this movie is going to be
adapted do you think it's going to be a
Batman vs Superman thing where somebody
pins one of them against the other or do
you think that venom is going to slip
into insanity and really become evil be
sure to hit me with all of your thoughts
in the comments down below don't forget
to hit the like button if you enjoyed
this video and don't forget to subscribe
to my channel so you can stay up to date
on everything relating to the MCU and so
you can enter my giveaway for a chance
to win an Xbox one or a ps4 don't forget
to follow me on Twitter and Instagram as
well and as always thank you all so much
for watching
woof woof